good morning my people it's your morning
shot of adrenaline rush we have taken
this show to number one do you see it I
can see you spoil those kids Oh Joe I've
been trying to be both parents you're
fortunate children to have all of this
if I was Santa I'd fly right over this
house it's too early for teachable
moments we appreciate everything you've
done @wm le but we are heading in a
different direction so that's it we're
out there it's hard on everybody I mean
not me cuz I'm cashing in big time well
I'm gonna tell the kids Christmas is
around the corner
we've been knocked down before it's
gonna have a little faith ever since
their mom died up you trying to be a
strong father for my kids I thought I
made it but I built him a life brush
you gotta rise above this nonsense what
if I told you and crush bqoo is for sale
you got your drink at that station we
should buy it with what my megawatt
smile
all right I want you to think big
picture this is our way out of this mess
event moving back into our old house
what there are five of us there is a
whole mess of people in that tiny house
let's face it we've gotten a little
bougie when you finish eating a pizza
please
I am always gonna provide for you kids
what have y'all this rush on the new WB
QL
[Music]
it's not what you've got it's what you
got around you
or an old you're trying your best oh my
god my heart can take how much I love
you right now
is your pops in Asia hey that's gonna
get they chestnuts roasted ain't it
[Music]
you